the military is not different than
business it's not better or worse than
business and that the lessons are just
much easier to see because the stakes
are higher in other words everything is
exaggerated so the good is really good
and the bad is really bad and the impact
of really good is obvious and the impact
of really bad is obvious and so I find
that it's a much easier place for me to
study leadership just because it's way
exaggerated right the other thing is
it's it's a deeply human culture because
the stakes are life and death right very
often and so in business we have
colleagues and co-workers they have
brothers and sisters
it feels really different you know when
you hear military talk about each other
they use words like love love they talk
about love of each other they talk about
Brotherhood they talk about sisterhood
the Marine Corps talks about the
intangibles right in business we think
everything's rational and we think
everything's calculated and the stuff
that's gooey we call those soft skills
right they're human skills there's
nothing soft about them there's hard
skills and there's human skills right we
downplay the stuff that is the fabric of
business we call it a company it is
literally a group of people it is a
company and the people are more
important and you go to the highest
levels the highest performers in the
military whether you go to the the seals
or some of the other special operators
right they'll talk about that it's the
human being that cannot be replicated
the human being is more important than
the technology in business we think the
technology is everything they understand
that greatness cannot be scaled right
they they talk about things like trust
not just performance as reasons and ways
to judge whether we should let someone
on our team in business we only want to
see what your performance was where else
you worked and what your
what your performance was in your
prioritization we never ever consider
trust I'll show you something so a good
friend of mine who was a Navy SEAL
showed me this chat out
Richard Tiffany I asked him who becomes
seals like hot [ __ ] seals are so great
right he says well when we evaluate
skills we look at two axes right we look
at performance and we look at trust
right performance is how good you your
job
Trust is your character the way they say
it is I may trust you with my life but
do I trust you with my money or my wife
right their seals nobody wants the
person in the bottom left corner the low
performer of low trust of course of
course everybody wants the person the
top right the high performer of high
trust of course what they learned is
that the person the top left the high
performer of low trust that's a toxic
team member they would rather have a
medium performer of high trust sometimes
even a low performer of high trust it's
a relative scale over the high performer
of low trust right now think about how
we do it in business we have a million
metrics for someone's trust performance
and minimal to no metrics for someone's
trustworthiness which means we keep
promoting and celebrating high
performers of low trust and we we
ourselves are building toxicity into our
own teams on our own leadership here's
the joke do you have any idea how easy
it is to find a high performer of low
trust go to any team and say who's the
[ __ ] and they'll all point to the
same person
[Applause]
but we don't do that now that person
doesn't get fired that person needs
coaching they have not been taught
leadership maybe they were a great
salesperson that doesn't make them a
great sales manager we got to teach
leadership we can't just expect cause
you're good at your job you're good at
leading other people to do the job you
used to do if they're uncoachable then
you can let them go same goes for the
low performer of high trust we easy find
those two it's actually nothing to do
with performance go to any team and say
who do you trust more than anybody who's
got your back no matter what when the
chips are down you would turn to this
person before anybody else they will
also alternate point the same person
they may or may not be a high performer
but they're probably your best natural
leader and you're a great team member
and if they're struggling performance
coach them and if they're uncoachable
then we can maybe ask them to leave but
we don't ask
and yet the highest performing
organizations on the planet consider
trust more important than performance in
business we don't
[Music]